JOHNNY LEE: Good
morning, everyone.
Hi.
It's great to be here.
My name is Johnny Lee, and
I'm excited to give you
an update on where we
are with Project Tango.
For those of you who are less
familiar with Project Tango,
one of the core beliefs and
ideas behind this project
is the fact that, when we place
our mobile phones on a table,
they don't actually
understand the things that
are around them.
They don't understand
the extents of the table
or the room that they are in.
In fact, almost all
of the information
that they provide
us is constrained
to this little
rectangle you see here.
They don't understand if we're
relaxing at home with family,
or if we're in our
workspace collaborating
with our coworkers,
or in a large lecture
hall such as this, all
facing in the same direction,
or having a nice intimate
dinner with friends and family.
And what we do heavily
depends on where we are.
How we feel, how we talk,
how we share information
with each other all depend
on this context of where.
And so rather than try to force
our entire lives into this very
small rectangle, what
Project Tango is trying
to strive for is we're
developing the hardware
and software technologies
to help everything
and everyone understand
precisely where they are,
anywhere.
Not just where there's good GPS
coverage, good Wi-Fi coverage,
or Bluetooth beacons, but
any building, any space,
anywhere where we can
go, the devices and tools
that we use also share this
understanding of space.
So last year we introduced
our Project Tango Tablet
Development Kit.
And this was the
first mobile device
with the sensors and
software to start
to work toward this journey.
It includes a 4 megapixel
2 micron camera,
integrated motion tracking
camera, and an integrated depth
sensor.
And all of these sensors
combined with the Project Tango
software stack allow
devices to understand
the physical movement
of the device, as well
as its surroundings.
If you actually look at
the-- although we announced
the tablet over a year ago, if
you actually look at the GFX
Bench, which is very
popular graphics
benchmark for mobile devices,
using the Manhattan 3.0 test,
the Project Tango devices still
rank among the highest marks
with regard to
processor performance
of ARM-based devices.
We're also really happy to
share that since we started--
since last year, we've also
started shipping our dev kits,
and 3,000 units are in the
field in the hands of developers
working on hundreds of apps.
In a partnership with NASA,
we are also able to have two
of our devices,
early prototypes,
shipped up to the International
Space Station atop
a 530,000-pound Antares
rocket from orbital sciences.
This collaboration
and partnership
is allowing NASA researchers
to use the technology in Tango
to one day help robots
potentially autonomously
navigate the space station.
So what happens when you
have devices that actually
have this sensing capability?
Well there's a few
different categories
that we think are really
interesting, one of which
is indoor navigation.
You can imagine
our devices one day
not just being able to
take you to the front door
of a building,
but could actually
navigate you all the way
to the door of the room
that you wanted to get to.
There's a project inside
of Google starting
to use Project Tango
devices to explore
helping the visually-impaired
navigate indoor spaces.
You can also use the tracking
and spatial reasoning
of the device to transform
parts of your home
into a game environment.
So I can build a castle
in my living room
and build a forest
in my bedroom.
And of course, there's
emerging new areas
that are all starting
to get exciting,
such as robotics, AR and VR,
which are all potentially
enabled by the 3D-tracking
capabilities in Tango, as well.
So to give you a briefing,
the core technologies
of a Project Tango device
and the software stack
that goes on top of
it break into three
different categories.
The first is motion
tracking, the second
is area learning, and
lastly, depth perception.
So motion tracking is actually
very similar to your computer
mouse.
If you imagine taking your mouse
and putting it on the table,
as you move it around
on the flat surface,
it tells you the
relative position
you are when you
put it on the table.
Project Tango devices
are very similar.
When you first start
your app, it'll
tell you your relative
motion relative to when
the app started.
But instead of just
being constrained to 2D,
it actually is full 3D.
You get X, Y, Z, as well as
three degrees of rotation.
The second major concept
is area learning.
And if you imagine
closing your eyes,
you actually have sort
of a mental memory
of the shape of Moscone.
You know roughly where
you are in this building.
You know roughly
how big the room
is, as well as your own
location within this room.
And it is that memory that
we call area learning.
So when a Project Tango
device enters a space
that it's previously been in, as
it starts to explore the space,
it will build a map.
And when it recognizes a
landmark it's seen before,
it can localize itself to
the rest of the building.
And that's called area learning.
The last major concept that
Project Tango devices provide
is depth perception.
So in Project
Tango-compliant devices,
we include a depth
sensor that uses
infrared signals to measure the
distance to points in space.
This allows us to detect the
floor, the walls, and furniture
in the environment,
and potentially
allows your application or game
to respond to the user's space.
Now over the past year, we've
made a ton of improvements
to the software stack.
And this is just a few of them.
This has been done
in collaboration
with some of our
early access partners
that we gave devices
to, and we really
appreciated their
feedback as we've
continued to push and push
the features of the system.
Now unfortunately,
due to time, there's
no way I could actually
talk through all of these.
So instead, I'm
going to show you
a short video that illustrates
some of these capabilities
in action.
Could we dim the lights?
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY LEE: It's pretty
neat stuff, isn't it?
And it's all working in real
time on our tablet development
kits.
Some of those videos
are very early
proof-of-concepts in
our lab, and so we're
happy to sort of share the
results as we develop them.
Now because a lot of these
actually run in real time,
I actually do want to try to
demo this stuff for you live.
So we can switch
over to the tablet.
Great.
So what we have here
is a diagnostic screen
that just shows off kind of
what's going on under the hood.
Again, we have our-- this is
the raw image from the motion
tracking camera.
This is a wide-angle
camera that gives us
a large view of the environment.
In fact, I can see my
fingers holding the device.
And you see these
green dots that
are colored in various
different ways.
And these represent the
optical computer vision work
that's going on that
actually is tracking
the flow of the image
in the camera scene.
We combine this data with
the gyro and accelerometer
in a tight sensor
fusion stack to generate
the plot in the upper right.
So like any mobile device,
they can turn left and right,
and you can see a
response to my movement.
But what's special about
a Project Tango device
is that I'm able to actually
move with and walk around
the room.
So if I draw a circle
with the device,
it continues to track in 3D.
And I can walk off the
stage, and reasonably
aggressively walk
around and hold it.
And it continues to
track my position
fairly robustly and accurately.
So again, I could just
unplug the HDMI cable.
I'm actually
tethered by this wire
so you guys can see
what's on the screen.
But this would
allow a user to walk
around their entire house
or the entire building
and continue to have
full 3D tracking.
Now I want to show you just
a couple of simple demos
just using the motion
tracking capability.
So this is a quick test demo.
It's sort of an homage to some
very popular world building
applications.
And all I'm doing is I'm-- yeah.
What's here is a
simple open grid.
And you can see I have
this radical in the middle.
And all I have to do
is move the device,
and it controls the virtual
camera inside of Unity.
If I use the tablet, I
can point at the ground
and push this Add button,
which will place a block.
And if I add a
few more blocks, I
can start building
the foundation,
a little plot of land to
build a small building.
So you can see it's
pretty natural.
All I had to do was just use
it like a camera controller.
And I bring up this
menu, and I can
build bricks-- I can choose
bricks to build a little ground
line, like this.
And I'm just pointing with the
tablet and hitting the button.
And I can actually
control it quite nicely
and precisely quite quickly.
So I'm placing
pillars for windows.
Let me add a roof line.
OK, so now I have
my walls built.
And let me build a
little wooden roof.
There we go.
So just in a few--
about a minute
or so, I was able to build
this little structure that's
located here in the middle the
screen-- middle of the stage.
And I can walk to left
and right and look at it
from different angles.
And because I have full
six-degree freedom tracking,
if I want to I can just
lean in and actually
go inside the house, like this.
[APPLAUSE]
So I picked a stone
brick, and now I
can start decorating
the inside of the house.
I did make kind
of a small house,
so I can't do a whole lot in it.
But the neat thing about it is
that this building is actually
here in the middle the stage.
If I come over here to
this part and I'm here,
I can build a small tower.
And these objects are actually
physically located in space.
So you can imagine if I
actually had a multiplayer
version of this, I could build
with my brother or my sister
or my friend sort of in
a collaborative manner,
and we could all be using
physical space in the same way
as if I were stacking with
real physical objects.
One of the things
we wanted to do
is make sure that working
with the Tango tablets
were actually very
easy for people
who already had 3D assets.
So Other World is
a game developer
that we helped--
or we asked to see
if they'd be willing to port
a game that they already had,
which was based inside of
Unity, to the Tango platform.
And if you use the SDK,
it's actually quite simple.
Within a matter
of a couple hours,
you can take a 3D asset in
Unity game you already have
and make it Tango-enabled.
So this is a world
where I have to help
the ship dodge these enemies.
And in a normal game, you
would-- in a normal device,
you would either tap
the screen to rotate
where you are on the
planet or rotate your head
with a gyroscope.
But because we have full
six-degree freedom tracking,
I can actually walk around
and look at the planet
from different sides.
If I want to go
above the planet,
I can dodge these
crystals and sort of
navigate him through
this space as
if this globe was
floating in front of me
and about two or
three feet away.
I can also back up and
start throwing asteroids
from the planet, just by
touching the asteroid belt.
So this is just a
demonstration of how
you might enable six-degree
freedom input into existing
game assets.
The other thing that we've
been asked by our developer
community was
being able to bring
in geometry of the real
world into the game engine.
So part of the
sample code that we
have on Project Tango
website is this app,
which is called Mesh Builder.
And what it's doing is
actually using the depth sensor
combined with the 3D
tracking to do a real-time 3D
scan of the stage.
So I have this small table
here with this basket.
And you can see, as I
walk around the stage,
it's actually progressively
building this mesh.
And because this is all running
real time inside of Unity,
I can throw balls
on it, and we're
updating the physics
in real time as well.
So this basket is actually
a little bit too small
for these balls, so let me take
this one away and give myself
a slightly more generous
basket right there.
So let me clear
this and rescan it.
And you can see it kind
of has the larger basket.
It's progressively
building itself in.
Now if I back up, I can
try to play basketball.
Come on.
Yeah!
[APPLAUSE]
So with a little bit
of additional help
and some procedural
game geometry,
you could actually turn this
table into a plateau or a mesa.
You could actually literally
have someone building
a set of cushions
with their couch,
and you could turn
that into a castle
and have your characters
actually run around furniture.
When we first got
this working, we
were like taping up
blankets in our office
and using them as
ramps for the ball.
Another simple
utility that we've
been asked for with
the sensors that you
can do-- with the sensors that
we have in a Tango device--
is being able to simply
measure the environment.
So imagine we are
shopping for a new table,
or I have a new bed that I
want to move into the space.
We can use the tracking
sens-- we can use the tracking
data, as well as the 3D
sensing data, to give us
a simple visual tape measure.
So for example, if I want to
measure the size of this table,
I simply use this crosshair,
point it at the table-- whoop,
let me try that again.
Do it down here.
OK.
So that gives us a rough
measurement of the environment
between those two points.
All I had to do was point the
device like it's a cursor,
and I can see the distance
between these two corners,
and come over here, and
just by pushing this button,
we get a rough measurement of
the footprint of this table.
The other nice
thing about this is
that you don't have to be
constrained to flat surfaces.
If I am trying to,
say, park a truck where
I have all my furniture
still inside of it
and I'm trying to figure out
if I can get through this gap,
I can measure from this table--
from this podium to this wall,
and it'll give us a measurement
in free space, just like that.
[APPLAUSE]
So there's a variety of
professional applications
you could already
start with imagining
being able to make use of this
technology and capability.
The last demo I want to
show you is from a partner
called [? Invive ?].
And what they do
is they specialize
in product visualizations.
They do high-end
apartment complexes,
they do products such as
cars and refrigerators.
And so we had been
working with them,
and they have this
simple car visualizer.
I need to actually
point in this direction
so that we can actually
place a car on the stage.
Let me actually pick
it up and move it
so it's not touching the table.
There we go.
So I can simply walk
around this car.
Because it's such
a-- it's actually
a full-size metric
car, it actually
doesn't quite fit on the stage.
So I'm going to use the power
of software and shrink the car.
There we go.
OK.
So now it's almost
toy-sized now,
but I can sort of look around.
I can look at the wheels,
I can double tap the hood
and it'll open up the engine.
I can get up close to
the engine and talk
about the different
parts inside of it.
The respirator, the
carburetor, the engine hood.
Obviously, you can
do customizations
to the visualizer, such
as making it a nice racing
red, or a midnight blue.
I think I can also go and
do body upgrades, which
I'll show different parts of the
car that I can edit and modify.
So let me just select the
roof and give it an upgrade.
And just for good
measure, let me scale it
back up to normal size,
which will actually
allow me to get in the car.
But there's not quite
enough stage space,
so I'm just going to go
right through the windshield.
But here I can actually
see the in-car dashboard,
the steering wheel, the seats.
If I want to, I can adjust
the interior styles, as well,
[INAUDIBLE] colors.
So this is just
another simple example
of our Unity integration.
And we started improving the
AR quality of performance,
the registration.
And again, it's important
to realize that this is all
using motion tracking.
There's no pre-existing
map of the stage,
and we could easily do
this in any environment,
including your home or a
show room or a retail space.
OK, so those are the demos.
[APPLAUSE]
Could we go back to the laptop?
A couple other demos
that I unfortunately
can't do on stage, or it's
very difficult to demonstrate,
is, of course, things like VR.
VR has obviously made a lot
of news and press recently,
and the [? sixth-off ?] tracking
and positioning that Project
Tango enables is
interesting for VR.
So we started exploring docking
these tablets to your face
using the Durovis dive helmets.
Durovis is a
partner that creates
these plastic shells for
different sized mobile devices.
It's obviously not the most
ergonomically-friendly form
factor.
And these tablets were
not designed for VR.
They have high
latency, they don't
have quite the right
rendering stack.
But from a sensor and
tracking standpoint,
they seem to be performing
relatively well.
So if you have time, you can
go out to our sandbox area
and you could experience
this village scene in VR.
You can look on
the ground and get
sort of to the ground
level of the people
and look around the
different bases.
We also have a prototype
of doing multi-user VRs.
Because we have fully
self-contained devices,
having multiple people
in the same space
is largely a matter of just
getting the Wi-Fi connection
working and having positions
shared among each other.
The great thing about this
is that you can actually
put on the helmet and you
can see each other in VR
and have an actual conversation.
The mouths actually move to
your vocal-- to the sound.
If you are on the sandbox
area, you probably
also saw one of this.
This is a prototype that
we built with Hasbro.
They have the NERF brand guns.
And what they did is
they built a 3D mount
that goes on the rail
system of the gun,
and you just put a Project
Tango-enabled device
and it allows you to
actually run around
the room in a
first-person shooter.
You can turn and shoot the
enemies from left to right,
but you can also move and duck
behind the boxes in the space.
It's a lot of fun
to actually play,
and so I encourage you
to try this one out.
So we're really excited
and proud to have
a large number of
partners that have helped
us mature this platform, both
from a software and hardware
standpoint.
And we hope to grow this
networking community
with hopefully some of
you in this audience we
can add to this list.
So Project Tango devices
we feel enable a new form
of digital playground.
We can put virtual objects in
the same physical space that's
meaningful to people.
We can actually
navigate you to the item
that you're really
interested in a space
that you've perhaps
never been before.
We can also help
you make decisions
about where to go
in play areas where
GPS may not be good enough.
We can enable you to not only
create 3D stories that you
could look around by
turning your head,
but you can actually
get up and walk through.
And I think this is an
interesting dimension
that we're only starting
to-- we're only beginning
to explore as a community.
Obviously, we're
all very excited
about the emergence
and maturity of AR.
And 3D tracking and
registration is a core component
of making a good
user experience.
And when you combine
that tracking ability
with information
about the environment,
you can actually see beyond the
physical limits of your space.
And we also know about
robotics and drones.
And I know I've
been an enthusiast
and bought one of these
myself, but I also crashed it
in the first 30 minutes.
So onboard mobile 3D positional
tracking and 3D sensing
is important for things
like collision avoidance
and autonomy.
So we also see the
technology in these devices
being relevant to
this domain, as well.
So this is our Project
Tango Development Kit,
with a high-performance 2
micron, 4 megapixel camera,
motion tracking camera,
integrated depth sensing,
the Tegra K1 processor with
128 gigabytes of storage
and 4 gigabytes of RAM, which
is on par with a lot of laptops.
And before we had to
request that developers
apply on our website
to get one of these.
So there was a relatively
limited distribution.
But we're actually
happy to announce
that earlier this week
we opened up purchasing
to anyone in the United States,
with international locations
coming soon.
We're also happy to say
that we are offering these
at a reduced price of $512.
Given the actual
specs of this device,
this is actually a pretty
aggressive price point.
To celebrate this new
availability of the devices,
we are also kicking off our
first app development contest.
So this is an effort to seed
app development and seed
content on our platform.
There's three categories
to the contest.
You can choose to
build a utility
app, such as measurement,
navigation, room scanning,
or object scanning.
We have a category for
AR and VR use cases.
And of course, gaming and
entertainment, which I think
is one of the ones that's very
easy to imagine seeing demos
in this space.
We have seed money for each
milestone for each category,
which exponentially increases.
So 16 selected proposals
will get $1,024.
Four selected working
prototypes after that milestone,
they'll get up to $2,048.
And then each category
will have one final app
selected with $4,096.
Once all the final apps
have been submitted,
we'll have a user-driven
contest-wide grand prize
of $8,192.
All told, together this
is a total cash awards
up to $95,000.
And we hope this won't be
the last contest we run.
So proposal entries start
today, and for deadline--
the first deadline that
you should be aware of
is June 25th, which is a
deadline for proposals.
The final APK entry will have to
be submitted by September 23rd.
To find out more information
about how to enter the contest
and details, please visit our
Project Tango Google+ community
page.
So $95,000 to help seed the
app development community.
And we hope this helps bring
up and surface new partners
that we actually want
to work with more deeply
and make a stronger
relationship with.
We are really excited about the
tech inside of Project Tango,
and we hope that one day it
can be as ubiquitous as GPS.
But we also know
that-- before we
used to be fine with phones
that didn't have GPS.
We knew how to get
from home to work,
we knew how to get to our
restaurants just fine.
But now we wouldn't even
consider buying a phone
without navigation directions.
And I think-- we believe
that the technology
inside of Project
Tango would enable
this sort of feeling as well.
But we also know that, to
become ubiquitous as GPS,
tablets are necessarily
the best form factor.
I'll be the first to admit that
a seven inch tablet doesn't
really fit in my pocket.
And we'd love to be able to
have people carry this around
with them all the time.
And so that's why we're also
excited to announce today
a new partnership.
And that's with Qualcomm.
Qualcomm is the largest
manufacturer of mobile phone
processors today, and
we've been working
with them over the
past few months
to try to incorporate the
Project Tango technologies
onto their chipsets.
And this is with great support
from Raj Talluri, Senior Vice
President at Qualcomm, who is
right here in the audience.
Do you want to
stand up and say hi?
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
We first met Raj
earlier this year,
and we sat down and
talked about the future
of Project Tango and
our goals and the future
of mobile computing.
And we both agreed.
And we agreed that computer
vision and 3D tracking
was going to be an essential
part of new mobile experiences
from indoor navigation to VR,
AR, and potentially robotics.
And we understood that
to actually achieve
the price and power
and performance
requirements of these new,
demanding applications required
developing new hardware
and new software.
And so we've been working with
very tightly with Qualcomm
engineers to modify their mobile
development platform, or MDP,
to incorporate
Project Tango sensors.
So this is a modified version
of Qualcomm's Snapdragon 810 MDP
platform.
We've incorporated it with
the motion tracking camera,
a new depth sensing camera,
which is time-of-flight based,
from a partner called
PMD Technologies, an RGB
camera, and timestamped
gyro and accelerometer.
And these are all of the
things that you need in order
to support the software's
experiences that we
want to do on this hardware.
So these MDP platforms
are the reference designs
provided to device
manufacturers to accelerate
the design of their
next generation phones
using Qualcomm chipsets.
So by working with Qualcomm
and building these devices,
we cannot only optimize
Project Tango software
to the Snapdragon chipset, we
can also accelerate the rate
of adoption in mobile phones.
Now it's important to remember
that these are engineering
reference designs,
so there's not
a plan to manufacture a
large quantity of these.
The best platform right now
that you can purchase today
is the Project Tango tablet.
But these will be given to OEMs
as well as software developers
to optimize some of
their applications
to the Snapdragon chipset.
We're really excited
about this partnership,
because we believe it's a
large milestone in being
able to bring this technology
to the pockets of millions
and billions of users.
So we're excited
about this future.
So today, you can now purchase
a Project Tango Development Kit
and actually start writing
apps as early as next week.
We hope to see what people
can do with this platform.
We've started a contest
to enable the applications
that we'll see
tomorrow, and we hope
to find new partners that we
can engage in more deeply.
And we're continuing
to invest heavily
in the software and
hardware required
to take this technology into
more form factors, including
the mobile phone and beyond.
So this is an investment
in things to come.
We see the exciting things
that technology is developing,
and we believe the future
is genuinely awesome
if we can work
together and bring
this technology to people.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
It does look like we have about
six minutes for questions,
if anyone has any.
Oh, I think it's best to
walk up to the microphone
if you do have a question.
I forgot to mention
we are hiring.
So you can go to our website
and look at our job listings.
The development kits and the
contest information can be
found on our website
and Google+ page.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
About the motion
tracking API, could you
comment on the accuracy
of the position
and pose given out by the SDK?
JOHNNY LEE: Sure.
So when the system is happy,
the accuracy is about 1%.
So with 100 feet of travel,
we drift about one foot.
So it's a function
of distance travel.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And you can say in percentage.
JOHNNY LEE: Yes.
It's more accurate to
talk about percentage,
because if you go a long
distance, it'll change.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
The contest is open to
all developers worldwide?
Or only for US?
It is open?
JOHNNY LEE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOHNNY LEE: Oh.
Yeah.
The Qualcomm device is actually
on display in the sandbox area.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So one of the demos showed
a user biking into the city
and then doing the
real time mapping.
So [INAUDIBLE] how
do I deal with being
used outside and [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHNNY LEE: So the
motion tracking camera
is a visible light imager,
so it works fine indoors
and outdoors.
The positional tracking and all
of the orientation information
uses just that camera
and the inertial sensor.
So indoors and outdoors
is not a problem.
AUDIENCE: So it can do object
detection outdoors, as well?
JOHNNY LEE: The tracking
can work outdoors.
The depth sensors
have a harder problem.
So some depth sensors have
more sunlight robustness
than others, and so depending
on the technology being used,
the outdoor performance of
depth specifically will vary.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And you also mentioned
using the Tango tablet
for AR and virtual reality.
What would be the latency in
the amount of data coming back
from [INAUDIBLE] and
back to the application?
JOHNNY LEE: So
the primary sensor
that drives a lot of
the frame updates in VR
is actually the gyro.
As you move your
head, that's the one
that creates the most visual--
significant visual feedback.
So there's no reason why, in
a properly optimized hardware,
that the gyro
performance would be
any different from
another VR headset.
But the tablets here are
running stock Android,
and there's not any particular
latency optimizations
on these devices.
So these devices are around
80 milliseconds or so,
but as I mentioned,
they're not optimized
for low-latency performance.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: You showed the
screenshot of the multi-user VR
chat.
How do the-- how does-- how
are the relative positions
between the multiple
users determined?
JOHNNY LEE: Sure.
So that's a good question.
So each device when
it first boots up
is its own coordinate frame.
So what we have is the
area description files,
which is the pre-existing
coordinate system for the room.
So by sharing the
area description
file with multiple devices,
either by pushing those
over the network or by
copying them manually,
all the devices will boot up
and localize to the same room,
essentially.
AUDIENCE: And that works by
detecting features in the room
and, like, mapping it to
that relative to the area
description file, or?
JOHNNY LEE: Right.
The area description file
is a visual description
of the environment which
includes features and matches
in that space.
So just like-- it would be
a description of this room.
And as long as we all shared
the same reference of the room,
we can all adjust
our coordinate system
to match the coordinate
system of the room.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
JOHNNY LEE: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER: We have time
for one final question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Two quick questions, please.
JOHNNY LEE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: How good does
it work in large rooms
with high ceilings, like,
for instance, this room.
If we would like to
map it, the whole room,
the entire whole room,
how accurate could it be?
JOHNNY LEE: So 1%
is probably still
the best metric I can provide.
So the further you
are from objects,
the more ambiguity there
is in the positioning.
So on the stage, while a
large percentage of the room
was empty, I was still able to
see the content on the stage.
And so this kept my
position accuracy
on the order of a few
millimeters to a centimeter.
If I went out into the
hallway and only pointed
at the ceiling, the
area would go up.
But as you walk around and build
more observations of the room,
it can become more
precise over time.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
And the second
question is, is it
possible to anchor
a specific point
to-- a longtitude/latitude
references to a geolocation?
JOHNNY LEE: Yes.
So in our indoor navigation
proof-of-concept,
we're currently doing that and
locating our area description
files.
So that requires some
other reference to say,
well, I know the
origin of the room.
But where's the origin of
the room on the planet?
AUDIENCE: Right.
JOHNNY LEE: So one of the
things we can use, of course,
is GPS or Wi-Fi, or some other
manual alignment process.
You could also
imagine, over time,
being able to collect
more area descriptors.
And as we connect more
and more of those,
we have enough GPS- and
Wi-Fi-based constraints
to give us a global
coordinate system,
or a global reference to
the coordinate system.
AUDIENCE: So if I anchor,
for instance, a window
and I tell this is the
latitude-- longtitude/latitude
of this window, as
I scan the room,
it could give me the--
automatically reference
me the other window that should
be the longtitude/latitude
for that window?
JOHNNY LEE: Yes.
So you will know your
offset to the window--
AUDIENCE: Right.
JOHNNY LEE: And
then you can apply
the positional coordinate system
of the window to your data set.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
JOHNNY LEE: Yep.
Great.
Well, thank you very
much, and I hope
you guys check out our sandbox.